well again uh now uh for the main event
again the resolution reads government
must play a role in fostering scientific
and technological progress by funding
basic research uh here for the
affirmative Tony Mills Tony please come
to the
stage speaking against the resolution uh
Terren Keeley Terren please come to the
stage Tony you have uh 17 and a half
minutes to establish your case you can
use the podium take it away
Tony okay thank you Jean and thank you
to the Soho forum and to uh Terence
Keeley I'll just Dive Right In
in 1785 the French chemist clae Louie
Berle determined the chemical
composition of ammonia a colorless
pungent gas that is an important natural
source of
nitrogen nitrogen itself discovered only
a few years before that is a chemical
element essential for life being a key
nutrient in the production of amino
acids proteins and nucleic acids
nitrogen is particularly important for
agriculture in the form of
fertilizers
yet while nitrogen is abundant in nature
its usable forms are rare so that
historically humans have been dependent
on scarce and finite sources for
instance from seabird guano manure
luminous plants and later byproducts of
cing coal several years after
determining the chemical composition of
ammonia Berto Advanced the theory of
chemical equilibria by discovering that
certain chemical reactions such as the
formation of sodium carbonate are
reversible contrary to scientific
opinion together berto's discoveries
suggested to future scientists that
ammonia a simple compound composed of
one nitrogen and three hydrogen atoms
could be synthesized from its
elements this would provide a steady and
renewable source of nitrogen and over
the course of the 19th century as as
Nations
industrialize abundant sources of
nitrogen became even more important to
feed the world's growing
population and chemists and engineers
sought without success to synthesize
ammonia almost a century after berto's
discoveries another French chemist AR L
chatelier refined the principle of
chemical equilibria and helped specify
the conditions under which ammonia could
be synthesized like his predecessors
however the chatellier tried and failed
and it was left to yet another chemist
the German Fritz hobber to provide a
successful laboratory demonstration of
ammonia synthesis which he did in
1909 hobber soon partnered with Carl
Bosch an engineer at the German firm
bisf and together they scaled the
synthesis of ammonia to Industrial
levels the Practical consequences are
difficult to overstate for starters the
industrial production of ammonia enabled
Germany after the outbreak of World War
I to circumvent the Allied blockade
including Imports of Chilean nitrates
and continue producing fertilizers and
Munitions at scale longer term and far
more significantly the synthesis of
ammonia went on to trans form Global
agriculture turbocharging the world's
food production and what is now referred
to as the Green
Revolution according to Czech Canadian
scientist faav smill the synthesis of
ammonia is quote the single most
important change affecting the world's
population without which the expansion
of the global population from 1.6
billion people in 1900 to 8 billion
today would not have been
possible bera's discoveries were of
course not by themselves sufficient for
the synthesis of ammonia it took num
numerous scientists and Engineers of
different nationalities and in different
fields and institutional settings over a
long period of time to achieve that but
Bar's work nevertheless did provide a
necessary foundation for the work of
habber and BOS over a century later even
though beray himself could not have
imagined the extent of the Practical
consequences of his
discoveries this is only one of many
such stories a different one with the
same moral could be told about the
English mathematician George Bull's
discovery of binary algebra in the 1840s
which the American engineer Claude
Shannon nearly a century later applied
to electrical relays and swi switching
circuits laying the foundation of the
modern digital computer which was
developed during World War II or
consider the Advent of electromagnetism
in the 19th century or of quantum and
relativistic physics in the 20th century
without which we would not have
electricity radar or radio nuclear
energy lasers or GPS or consider the
discovery of messenger RNA in the early
1960s by American French and British
biologists which enabled scientists such
as Cataline Kiko over half a century
later to De to help develop the MRNA
vaccines that saved millions of lives
during the covid-19 P
pandemic what these stories all
illustrate is something that may seem so
simple as to pass Us by which is that
scientific discoveries especially in
what is often called basic science can
enable transform
indeed world changing technological
innovations that greatly benefit the
public and this is a major reason reason
why the federal government does and
should continue to support basic
science is only the state capable of
doing so of course not the private
sector has and continues to fund basic
Sciences well but Private Industry is
quite understandably primarily concerned
with commercial results and thus tends
to not only have its own research
priorities but also to operate on a
timeline that is from a historical point
of view extremely short but as the
examples described earlier indicate the
quote unquote payoff from basic
scientific discoveries whether economic
medical military or other often comes
from unexpected places and can also take
decades unsurprisingly industry has
never devoted more than a small share of
its research budget to basic science the
public sector meanwhile though it funds
much less research than the private
sector overall today Remains the single
biggest patron of basic
science science and technology flourish
in a complex ecosystem of Discovery and
invention that depends on a wide variety
of Institutions goals incentives and
kinds of research Private Industry plays
an enormously important role here
especially in using science to develop
commercially viable products that
benefit Society such as
vaccines but basic science traditionally
housed within academic institutions is
also vitally important and the state is
best positioned to to ensure that it has
adequate Support over the long
term the idea that science is vital for
technological innovation is an important
rationale for federal science funding
and indeed an important aspect of the
self-identity and public image of modern
science but it was not always true and I
want to offer some historical background
uh to contextualize the argument I'm
making tonight and our debate more
generally for most of History
technological development was not in
fact dependent on advances in science
many of History's impressive
technological achievements the water
wheel the mechanical clock the Mariner's
Compass eyeglasses gunpowder long
predated the Scientific Revolution
inaugurated by cernus in the 16th
century even the industrial revolution
of the of the 18th century though it
came after the Scientific Revolution
cannot be understood as the
straightforward result of the Scientific
Revolution indeed with few notable
exceptions the inventions of the first
Industrial Revolution did not derive
from nor could be described as
applications of capern astronomy
Newtonian mechanics or Optics or even
the chemistry of Bo or
liser this is not to denigrate these
achievements or their inventors nor to
deny any link between science and
Innovation during this time but it is to
point to the fact that science then
known as natural philosophy remained
quite distinct from what was known then
as the mechanical Arts the latter being
associated with the craft guilds which
aimed not at knowledge for its own sake
but rather satisfying basic human
needs this would change in the 19th
century with the rise of what historians
call the second Scientific Revolution
this was a period of astonishing
scientific growth as well in the
mathematical Sciences to name just a few
developments we saw the rise of modern
probability Theory and statistics formal
logic binary algebra and non- ukian
geometries in the physical sciences
electromagnetism spectroscopy
thermodynamics organic and inorganic
chemistry and statistical mechanics in
the Life Sciences evolutionary bi ology
physiology pharmacology and
bacteriology these advances all paved
the way for even greater advances in the
20th century with the rise of quantum
and relativistic physics as well as
modern genetics biochemistry and
molecular
biology The Sciences of this second
Scientific Revolution greatly enhanced
our Mastery over Natural Forces thus
enabling practical Innovations of all
kinds from telegraphy to laboratory
based vaccines science also became
integrated into practical domains such
as medicine and engineering
giving rise to the modern scientific
professions familiar to us
today and science became increasingly
important to Industry with the rise of
Industrial Research and ultimately
entire science-based industries from
electricity to Pharmaceuticals to
telecommunications it was also during
this period and for similarly practical
reasons that the US federal government
began to take an active interest in
science beginning in the middle of the
19th century and accelerating after the
Reconstruction Era Congress created or
expanded a number of science science
bureaus from the US geological and Coast
surveys to the Weather Service to the
Army signal Corps to the Department of
Agriculture to Grapple with a variety of
practical challenges faced by the
growing and industrializing Nation this
drew the federal government into
supporting a wide array of scientific
activities including increasingly basic
science for instance spurred by the 1878
yellow fever epidemic Congress
established the national board of health
a short-lived Institution whose purpose
was to study the causes of and methods
of controlling yellow fever which had
plagued the American South since the
country's founding the board launched
the nation's first system of federal
grants and aid for medical and public
health research the hygienic laboratory
was also founded during this this period
And by the early 20th century had
expanded Beyond its original purview on
infectious and communicable diseases
into basic research on the biological
and chemical processes and mechanisms
underlying chronic diseases and other
public health
challenges or during World War II later
the Public Health Service and the newly
formed National research Council
pioneered methods of supporting and
coordinating academic research to tackle
such wartime problems as venial disease
among soldiers submarine detection and
chemical
warfare following the war reformers
inspired by such coordinated research
sought to establish a new chemo Medical
Institute to promote scientific research
for medical purposes failing to find
adequate Financial support from private
companies and philanthropies these
reformers turned reluctantly to the
federal government resulting in the
ranell Act of 1930 which expanded and
renamed the hygienic laboratory the
National Institute of
Health the second world war would see a
dramatic expansion of federal science
with the large- scale mobilization of
research epitomized most famously by the
develop development of radar mass
production of penicillin and the
creation of the atom bomb Federal
science would continue to expand after
the war with the creation of the Office
of Naval Research and the atomic energy
commission and the National Science
Foundation all of which fund basic
science and federal science would expand
further still during the Cold War
especially after Soviet Russia's launch
of Sputnik 1 in 1957 the first
successful artificial Earth satellite
this was another period of Bureau
building with the growth or creation of
such familiar research agencies as NASA
and the advanced research project agency
now known as DARPA
the state's growing interest in science
over this Century long period was
spurred by crisis in particular disease
and War and it must be admitted the
sometimes self-serving efforts of
reformers who sought to take advantage
of these crises to implement reforms
they had sought all along yet the growth
of the scientific establishment could
not fairly be described as a ploy by
which scientists dup the state into
plundering public coffers for public for
private gain as is sometimes suggested
by critics the emerging partnership
between science and the state was
entered into reluctantly with mutual
suspicion on both sides it was through
grappling with the Practical problems
that clearly fell within the purview of
the state from mapping the country's
coasts waterways and expanding Frontier
lands to protecting public health and
providing for the National Defense that
science and the state came to recognize
their Mutual
dependence the resulting system though
it can many successes is far from
perfect my purpose here is not to defend
every aspect of it but rather than
seeking to sever signs from the state a
politically impossible goal even if it
were desirable we should instead seek to
reform the federal scientific
establishment ensuring that there is
ample support for basic science should
be a key aspect of any program for
reform so to conclude my opening remarks
I'd like to make an important caveat to
my
argument neither the claim that basic
science enables technological innovation
nor that the state should therefore fund
basic science should be confused with
what is sometimes called in policy C CES
the linear model of innovation this is
the idea that technological innovation
follows a strict one directional process
that moves from basic research to to uh
application to commercialization thus
stimulating economic growth despite
remaining pre prevalent in economic and
policy circles this assembly line
picture of innovation is rightly
rejected by nearly all Scholars today as
simplistic and misleading the
relationship between science and
Innovation is not linear first hardly
all technological innovation depends on
basic scientific discoveries as we saw
earlier nor are all scientific
discoveries nent technological
innovations the term basic is
potentially misleading here as it
implies that all scientific discoveries
form the Bas basis of something else but
this is an excessively narrow and
instrumentalist conception of science
Cernic's achievement in developing a
heliocentric model of the cosmos did not
provide the basis of any technological
innovations even though it ushered in
the Scientific
Revolution even in those instances where
basic science does enable technological
innovation however the relationship
between the two is hardly
straightforward but rather complex and
dynamic Science and Technology knowledge
and use Discovery and invention these
often feed back on each other and
mutually beneficial and unpredictable
ways thus while beray scientific
discoveries enabled the synthesis of
ammonia it was the recognition of the
Practical consequences that pushed
chemists to solve this problem spurred
not only by scientific interest but also
by the potential practical
benefits moreover the problem was solved
through collaboration between scientists
engineers academics and people in
Industry entrepreneurs walking working
across time and space in different
countries fields and institutional
settings and over decades something
similar could be said about the
invention of the computer radio radar
atomic energy and modern
vaccines yet though we should reject the
linear model we should not reject the
idea that science including basic
science can enable technological
innovations that benefit the public that
would be to throw the baby out with the
bath water the importance of science to
technological innovation and thus to
economic growth is arguably one of the
most important socioeconomic changes of
the last 200 years basic science is
neither always necessary nor by itself
sufficient for technological innovation
but it nevertheless can enable and has
enabled technological innovations that
benefit the public in almost
incalculable ways as with the synthesis
of ammonia or modern vaccines the state
should not fund basic science because
turning on the spigot of federal funding
will inevitably produce wondrous
innovations that will pay off
economically the state should fund basic
science rather to ensure that there is a
flourishing ecosystem of Discovery
invention and that should include ample
support for the kind of research that
though not undertaken primarily for PR
practical benefits nevertheless can
produce such benefits albeit sometimes
many years later thank
you
we from Terence key uh Terren take it
away so thank you Jee for having invited
me thank you
Tony um of course I agree with almost
everything Tony said I don't need to be
persuaded that basic science is
important but what Tony has omitted is
the concept of crowding
out the Assumption behind his argument
and the Assumption behind most people's
assumptions are that when the government
funds basic science or indeed applied
science it's adding to what the private
sector would otherwise have done but the
evidence
unfortunately is that when governments
fund science basic or applied what it
actually does is it crowds out the
private funding back a little bit closer
oh sorry uh let me repeat that um so the
assumption that many people make is that
when government funds basic science or
applied science you end up with
additional science in addition to what
the private sector would have funded the
tragedy is the Converse that when
governments fund science applied or pure
it crowds out the private funding and
I'll explain how that works first though
a quick note of the history and many of
the facts I shall give are the same as
Tony's but they will have a different
interpretation
so
the story starts with Francis Bacon in
16005 400 years ago an English uh
scholar who suggested that governments
should fund science because the Spanish
and the Portuguese had discovered the
new world because their governments
funded science and therefore the English
should do the same the problem with the
argument is that it wasn't true and that
the Spanish and Portuguese didn't fund
pure science and the person who
demolished that argument was uh Adam
Smith the most important event of 1776
as everybody knows was the publication
of um uh a
book there was another event which was
unfortunate but we're
not we're not going to go into that what
Smith showed from particularly his
friendship with James Watt who is his
neighbor in Glasgow who basically made
the steam engine work was what James wat
had done an unlettered Tech
is it invented the separate condenser
for the steam engine which turned the
steam engine into the iconic instrument
of the Industrial
Revolution and it was contained within
the patent the first law of
thermodynamics so what what had done is
he had discovered the first law of
thermodynamics out of his work in
transforming the world's economy
actually and so Adam Smith came up with
a theory and which he showed
comprehensively
in The Wealth of Nations that
governments should not fund science
because it was
unnecessary because actually
universities depended on industry and we
have now one of the great natural
experiments of all
Humanity because for the last 3 or 400
years the Europeans under autocratic
regimes funded science very very
generously the French and German
governments funded science the British
and the American governments inspired by
Adam Smith did not and that changes and
here I agree with Tony only after the
second world war but now we have a 300E
span we have less a fair science with
the British and the Americans and we
have D government funded very generous
science in France and Germany well who
creates the Industrial Revolution the
British who creates the Second
Industrial Revolution the American
Americans who doesn't even Converge on
Britain and France on Britain and
America let alone overtake France and
Germany as late as
1940 uh the Germans for example their
GDP per capita was only 2third of that
of the United States just as it had been
200 years
earlier Everything Changes in 1940 1957
the American government did fund science
before the second world war but they
funded and it's a very important to have
a distinction between the two types of
funding model you have the mission
science model and you have the linear
science model now the mission science
model we could all support and this is
when the American government decides to
fund the co- survey or the Library of
Congress if these institutions these
missions need research sure they'll fund
it what happened after Sputnik
particularly was the American government
did convert to to the linear model that
was vanar Bush's book science the
endless Frontier and contrary uh here I
do slightly disagree with Tony there
were some scientists who were skeptical
but absolutely this was Bush leading a
group of scientists saying to the
American government we are terrified
that you'll do to us what you've always
done so until the second world war the
American government funded Mission
research things like its missions and it
funded research during wartime so the
National Academy of Sciences was created
in the Civil War for example but at the
end of these wars it stopped funding and
indeed venar Bush's um uh huge
organization the osr or or the
organization of scientific research and
development was disbanded in 1947 so you
have this enormous amount of science
being funded that's disbanded because
until the end of the second world war
the American government funded only
Mission
research Bush tried to persuade the
government that they needed pure science
in the linear model that Tony is now
very skeptical about but for many years
everyone believed that that was the way
forward and so the American government
started to fund pure science so let's
have my one and only
Slide the
SL
yeah so here you have from 1820 to the
present day actually for various reasons
198 5 but that'll do and these are log
curves so on the left you have rates of
GDP per capita growth in the United
States of America since 1820 and as you
can see GDP per capita has grown about
2% a year for the last 200 years fine
Britain looks pretty similar Germany and
France by the way don't look nearly as
healthy because they don't Converge on
the right oh can I have my slide back
please
guys on the right I'll talk you through
is the American government after back
thank you after the launch of Sputnik a
log curve remember this is log curve
Federal expenditure on basic science and
it goes from in 19 uh uh fix dollars it
doesn't matter what year 20 million in
1940 today it's 20 billion there in in
in fixed dollars the expansion by the
American government into pure science
has been explosive three orders of
magnitude such as pure science in
America until recently was dominated by
the federal government and the
consequences to economic growth well you
can see for yourself the dip by the way
is the Great
Depression it's not that I'm not
claiming that s well I am actually that
science caused the Great Depression I'm
just pointing out that that's what that
dip is so we've done the experiment
we've and and the American government
pouring money into pure science has done
precisely nothing to rates of economic
growth you can take it away now if you
don't like the slide
um there
are no fewer than eight important
American government studies showing that
the government funding of pure science
has done absolutely nothing for American
technological or economic growth um uh
so I will just mention their names in
1969 the director of Defense research
and engineering engages in a project
known as project hindsight showing that
the American government invention in
pure science has done absolutely nothing
for military capacity in the states in
74 and 1980 two years the national
Planning Association which is a
thinktank but very closely associated
with the government rather like Rand
does a series of studies on productivity
growth and concludes strong correlation
of private funding of R&D with economic
and productivity growth no benefits from
the Public Funding in 1986 the office of
Technology assessment one thing that
Tony and I agree on it's a shame that
office has gone but in 1986 the office
of technological assessment says that
the private return on R&D is 20% there
is no public return on R&D I public
funded R&D no economic benefit in both
1991 and 1998 the Congressional budget
office finds exactly the same thing I
quote returns to private r are high
those to Federal R&D low to non-existent
actually if you look at the data
non-existent in 2003 the
oecd not only does the oecd find that
there's no Government funding that
stimulates economic growth it finds that
Government funding inhibits economic
growth this is across the entire oecd
countries over a 25y year period
Government funding of R&D actually slows
economic growth as an empirical
observation and in 2007 the Bureau of
Labor Statistics only private R&D
generates income so why why is it that
all these empirical studies performed by
government
agencies show that um the government
funding of R&D and indeed basic science
has no economic benefit it's because of
crowding out and in 2018 a paper by Two
Italian economists arib Buji and Philip
petti they also looked at the oecd over
a 25e period and they chronicled this
crowding out now this is this paper is
interesting because it's written by two
men who really dislike me and the the
paper is full of really unpleasant
remarks about me which I could have done
without but what they show they blame me
what they show is that in
1964 the American government funded two3
third of all R&D in America 2third if
you're a Midwest company wanting to do
research you wrote a grant to the
Commerce Department absolutely insane
and since 1964 this has now gone down
and today the American government like
oecd governments everywhere the American
government funds only 20% of American
R&D and 10 and half of that is defense
so only 10% of American Civil R&D is
funded by the
state in that time
there therefore has been across the oecd
a fall in the Public Funding of R&D I
could give you the data but let me just
say that but the consequence has been a
growth in the private funding
threefold for every dollar the P the
public sector has withdrawn from the
funding of research the private sector
has put in three extra dollars more than
compensate now AR Arie uji and filipetti
say admit that this is crowding out they
don't pretend it's not crowding out they
claim it's a bad thing we could go into
that that they are of course wrong but
the reason is why no it is a good thing
because it's where that it's techn
industry is where technology comes from
what is the mechanism of crowding out
the mechanism is s scientific quality if
the government creates universities that
all the best scientists go to and the
best scientists go to universities I
mean we're all used to now Silicon
Valley and that sort of thing we all
understand that good scientists can
create companies and do nonetheless the
majority of scientists are like Jane
Austin they're looking for fame they go
to
universities if you take the best
scientists out of the market and put
them into universities you leave
industry with the not so good scientists
and therefore industry doesn't get a
return on its investment and therefore
it looks for other ways of making money
marketing or something and so the
government funding of research which
others not me I mean I have also shown
it but the point is others have shown
creates crowding out 3 to one it's a
very serious crowding out takes the best
scientists out of industry and therefore
damages rates of economic growth now we
are
told that governments have to fund
science because the market
disincentivizes companies from doing
science so the myth that we are told by
The Economist is if I do science I'll be
disincentivized because my discovery
which cost me a lot of money to make
Tony will take for nothing in his
company and therefore for him the
discovery is free for me it costs a lot
of money therefore he will outperform me
I will go bust and he'll make all the
profit that is the story The economists
tell and it is a story based on an utter
myth that assumes that knowledge is
what's called explicit but actually
knowledge is tacit there's no way that I
say making iPhones I'm going to be
competed with except by other companies
making mobile phones and they are uh
capable of copying my research only by
the research they themselves have done
over the previous 20 30 years which has
given the expertise to copy my research
and vice versa so the cost of copying
you can show are actually 100% on
average the marginal costs are less than
100% but the average or the total cost
is 100% it costs as much to copy on
average as it does to innovate so it's
just a myth that the market doesn't
reward science actually the company that
says that uh it's not going to defund
science because it's worried about its
discoveries being copied by other people
should be told fine don't do science and
see how long it takes you before you go
bankrupt not very long so to summarize
the American government didn't fund
science
here Tony and I agreed on the facts
until the second world war and
particularly Sputnik when the Americans
suddenly thought oh my Heavens we're
going to be overtaken by the Russians
that really was the belief and what is
interesting is what the American
government funded in 1957 because it's
exactly as Tony says NASA and ARA now
known as DARPA the American government
recognized that the linear model the
National Science Foundation model had
failed the Russians were in face and so
they went back to the traditional model
of mission science when you have a
particular Mission governments can
actually deliver on that mission
governments can actually deliver on atom
bombs they can deliver on operation warp
speed give a government amission and it
can succeed the myth the dangerous myth
is that the government funding of pure
science through the linear model is
itself a stimulus to economic growth
someone whom Tony and I both know wrote
in the magazine that Tony once edited
new Atlantis that the linear model is a
lie and it is it's a lie it's been
promoted heavily by governments it's
promoted by because they want the
glory when the human genome was was
sequenced in the year 2000 who announced
it to the world Bill Clinton the great
patron of science so governments want to
fund science Industry wants to fund
science because it thinks wrongly it's
getting money back for its taxes it
thinks it's getting a subsidy scientists
want government to fund science because
they don't want to work for industry
they want to work in a peer-reviewed
system so they basically fund themselves
according to the science they want to do
and the general public believes somehow
that governments should fund science
because we all want to see programs on
Netflix about penguins and
things what has actually happened is
that that model has failed the
government knows it has failed there's
been this fantastic collapse in the
government funding of research and
development and the consequence has only
been an accelerated rate of economic
growth thank you very
much uh attorney uh 7 and a half minutes
for your btal you can take the podium or
do it from your whever you want take
okay
sure
um thank you uh so there's actually
quite a bit of agreement I think between
um Dr key and myself um and I just want
to point to a few points of important
disagreement yeah can you hear me okay
um so just to start and maybe come back
to this if I have time if you you'll
notice that in the course of uh
terrence's remarks he moved from science
uh enabling technological innovation to
science stimulating economic growth as
me measured in aggregate statistics and
so forth and here uh he and I are in a
lot of agreement I think the arguments
on on behalf of of that model and the
linear model associated with it um are
not persuasive I tend to read the
economics literature a little bit more
ambivalently but I'm a philosopher by
training not an economist so I leave
that to the economists um but the
argument that I've been making um in
which our proposition um I believe is
about is the relationship between
science and technological innovation
which isect Ed with economic growth but
a distinguishable Point um I want to
make a few I come back to that if I have
time but I want to make a few historical
observations so we do agree on a lot of
the same facts but there are some
important differences not only in
interpretation but also in some factual
details that I think are important um so
do Dr ke and I are in complete agreement
that uh the first wave of
industrialization can't be explained by
federal science funding I would go
further and say it can't be explained by
science really at all um where we
disagree is about how to interpret this
fact so I don't think we can draw useful
inferences uh from England in 1790 about
Federal science policy today any more
than private Enterprises today could
draw lessons about Industrial Research
policy from private Enterprises in
1790 there was no research in Industrial
Research in 1790 just as there was no
federal scientific establishment or even
any research universities in the modern
sense um so to pose the question
adequately we have to look at the
changes that happened in the intervening
time which is what I uh pointed to in my
opening
remarks um a few other historical
observations
um while it is certainly true that
Federal science funding exploded with
World War II and increased after it is
not accurate to say uh that the federal
government United States didn't fund
science before that nor would I suggest
is it entirely accurate to say that the
government didn't fund any basic science
uh certainly the majority of that
research was mission research uh as Dr
key described it but as I described in
my opening remarks it was through these
missions through the Practical practical
concerns of the state the federal
government became increasingly involved
in basic research already by the uh
early 20th century I would argue even
before that uh by which I mean funding
academic research including through a
system of Grants and Aid pioneered by
the national board of health developed
later by the Public Health Service um
beginning with uh the Cancer Institute
on Harvard's campus that was later gred
into the National Institutes of Health
uh in the Forerunner of the National
Institute of Health which I mentioned
and it's worth noting I think that
health research didn't figure
prominently in Dr K's opening remarks
either um uh health research by the time
of the Opera of World War II um was not
supported on the nearly the scale that
it came to be after the second world war
but did receive uh for the time quite
generous Federal support and was already
moving toward basic research part of the
difficulty here is that parsing the
distinction between basic and other
kinds of research is actually quite
difficult and so it often turns out
whether the government or industry is
funding practically oriented research it
can wind up needing to fund uh basic
research okay um the other thing I would
note something that was omitted in uh
the discussion of the post-war period is
that while the federal government did
absolutely increase Federal funding for
basic research it never has including
during that period devoted anywhere
close to the majority of its Federal
funding to basic science if you look at
the postwar period basic science makes
up a small fraction of O overall Federal
R&D and so if we're going to distinguish
between Mission research before World
War II we have to distinguish between
Mission research after World War II most
Research In the postwar period as it
still does today uh comes uh in the
federal context is military in the
postwar decades it was associated with
NASA which was mainly a large scale
engineering project to build rockets and
put people on the
moon um so this is a again this is not
to deny in absolute numbers that the
funding for basic did increase um okay I
want to which with my remaining few
minutes here pivot back to the question
of economics and technological uh
Innovation so uh we're in complete
agreement that the linear model is
inadequate I also uh uh would affirm Dr
Key's argument about um science and
scientific knowledge not being mere
information but requiring tacit
knowledge uh there are some I think
subtle differences between us on this
maybe we can get into in a but the main
thing I want to emphasize here is that
my argument is not premised on an
economic one based on an assumption
about public goods or the linear model
or crowding out or crowding in the
examples that I gave were historical
might dismiss them as mere anecdotes but
they are very significant anecdotes to
dismiss them as anecdotes would be like
dismissing putting a man on the moon as
a mere anecdote and what these examples
show and illustrate is that the timeline
and the predictability of the way in
which basic science can en enable
technological innovation first the
timeline is enormously long by the
standards of uh industry and frequently
even by government and that the domains
from which those Innovations uh May
develop are very hard to predict in
advance so if we just look again Jo
George Bull's discovery of binary
algebra in the 1840s enabling Claude
Shannon to apply that to Computing in
the 1930s it's almost a century and that
wasn't even the beginning of the modern
computer yet a similar timeline between
Bar's discovery of Amon of the
composition of ammonia 1785 to the
synthesis of ammonia over a century
later it would be unrealistic to expect
Private Industry to consider those sorts
of timelines in making its research
priorities and this is one of the
primary reasons why it is difficult to
uh for the private sector to sustain
basic science uh Beyond its commercial
interests not not for any reasons
relating to uh uh crowding out the other
piece I might add here in conclusion is
that the priorities of of uh Industrial
Research search do not always align um
with some public interests for why we
might want science Health being an
obvious example the private sector does
lots of health related research but the
public sector can play a role in uh
prioritizing certain areas of research
that might um be less immediately
profitable for industry um so I'll leave
it there maybe through question and
answer we can get into some more detail
thanks 7 and a half minutes robberto
from you take it away challeng so of
course we're agreed that basic science
is important that's not the issue
um industry does much more basic science
than I was going to call him Tony
perhaps I would call him Dr Mills he
kept on calling me Dr key um B industry
funds on average 7% of its budgets are
spent on basic science when you see how
vast Industries budgets are 7% of basic
of Industries R&D on Basics SS these are
huge budgets moreover it's been known
for 20 30 40 years even there's a direct
correlation between the amount of money
a company spends on pure and basic
science and its subsequent profits pure
science is very profitable to Industry
and Nathan Rosenberg in particular wrote
a paper explaining that companies spend
all their time copying each other that's
what they do and so they should and the
best people for copying other people's
science it turns out to basic scientists
we can go into why that is let's just
accept that as an empirical fact and you
won't keep basic scientists unless you
allow them to do basic science and so
companies end up funding an astonishing
amount of basic science simply because
it's so commercially valuable now Tony
talked about the unexpected nature of
science but that happens in Industry as
well Bell labs for example Bell Labs
discovered the science of radio
astronomy because their telephone
Engineers kept on the long of the line
the more the interference in the end
they realize it came from the Stars
Nobel Prize Bell Labs discovered the
background Cosmic radiation from The Big
Bang they weren't looking for it it's
just a consequence of the applied
science they were doing and we could
carry on with that we get um anecdotes
from uh Tony and they're fine but the
anecdotes the other way around the
airplane was discovered by private
workers who beat the state funded
workers and we could continue with such
anecdotes as well anecdotes are
dangerous which is why I like to try
personally to go for the systematic
economic data which shows very clearly I
would I would suggest that the
government funding of basic science does
nothing for economic growth but does
crowd out the private funding um so
rather than take up any more time having
made these points I shall just just
finish with one little Point Tony
started with Fritz Harbor who discovered
nitrogen and of course it's very
important but Fritz Harbor's wife killed
herself because she was married to a
monster because thanks to the German
government he also invented the gas es
that murdered thousands of soldiers on
the Western Front and actually and
there's a paradox here and a cruel
Paradox here because he was Jewish he
actually launched the industry that led
to Horrors in the second world war that
was government
funded when Fritz Harbor was working in
the private sector he did Fabulous
work the moment he was corrupted by
state funding
thank
[Applause]
you uh well uh we now go to the Q&A
portion of the evening and uh people are
welcome to line up and ask uh questions
uh let me take prerogative U moderator's
prerogative to lob a question at each of
you uh and then have the other comment
on it um uh Terren uh key uh you you you
are dismissive uh aru
argumentatively of some of the stories
that Tony has
recounted uh just want to make it clear
uh that he started with something
involving Agriculture and discovering
nitrogen and all the rest you you do
acknowledge I take it that um according
to you at least if you can cherry pick
some anecdotes that do justify even the
linear model that that is possible
you're saying you you acknowledge that
he told a few stories that are plausible
even uh replicating the line model that
he himself said isn't always Val
government did it and then it led to
something good that has happened you
acknowledge that do I talk into this
does this work yes of course um when
government has funded as much research
and development as it has funded
something good good is going to come out
of it uh the question is would it would
more good have come out of it if the
government hadn't funded and therefore
researchers had been allowed to work
within industry which is much more
applied to economic growth and I would
argue that the answer to that is yes and
you talk about
agriculture never forget that one of the
Mi one of the few missions the American
government funded for many years was
agricultural research why because of the
problems of
overproduction American farmers were
poor for more than a century because the
private sector inventing things like
barbed wire whatever or or the cotton
gin made agriculture too productive and
when it becomes too productive there's
no profit for individuals there is no
evidence that agriculture has ever
needed Government funding other than
pacifying bloody-minded voters who vote
against you because the F they're
unhappy about their over productivity
and therefore lack of profits I see um
uh any comment from you Tony about that
question uh sure yeah I I would maybe
disagree but in a way that might seem to
support you in a certain way I actually
don't think there are many historical
examples that support the linear model
so the examples that I gave are examples
where scientific discovery in
unpredictable ways and over a long
period of time enable technological
innovations that's true but that's if
that's the linear model then I suppose I
would endorse it but the linear model as
it's um understood is a very narrow
conception of how the pieces involved in
Innovation inter relate it's a you one
directional process you know basic
science happens over here it has nothing
to do with practical application um and
it is sufficient to generate
technological innovation almost
effortlessly um that leads to commercial
application and and economic growth and
I think that's that model doesn't hold
up and one of the reasons why it doesn't
hold up is that the historical record uh
is is much much more complicated that's
why I would differentiate between the
linear model which we should all reject
and you know your uh your good friend
Dave ederton has even written on this
it's so implausible as an account of
innovation that there's an entire field
of science studies devoted to figuring
out how everyone how anyone even came to
believe it and in fact there's not a lot
of evidence that anyone in fact ever
really believed it at least maybe
outside of uh some economists um so we
should all reject the linear model but
that should not lead us to throw out the
baby with the bath water as I was
arguing and and also go further and say
scientific uh Discovery including
scientific discovery that might be
pursued for purely non-practical or
different practical reasons can
nevertheless generate technological
technological innovations and that is a
reason why the federal government should
support it yeah um then uh just one
question for Tony and then we'll go to
uh questions from the audience um as you
know uh really the sort of the key
phrase from uh Terren is crowding
out uh that uh that that that you're
implying in his view that uh Government
funding can only add rather than
subtract let me introduce a related
question about something and your
maintaining that for-profit companies in
their very nature are not going to
invest a lot in basic research beyond
that however my question to you is U we
have a a looked up the numbers just the
other day a half a trillion dollars in
official philanthropy in this in 2020
last year a half a trillion dollars and
uh much of it went to medical research
uh the the philanthropic dollar seems to
like research uh certainly a lot of rich
people would love a cure for cancer I I
think we could have raised a lot of
money for a covid vaccine and then the
government wouldn't have protected Ed
those those companies against lawsuits
um so the question is uh in you in do
you acknowledge the possibility that
for-profit companies actually do more
than you're employing and therefore
there is a little bit of crowding out
and then introducing the separate
question which is that philanthropy
really likes research and that and
despite the fact that we think the
government is doing it all philanthropy
is immense so that's my two basic
challenges to you could you comment sure
yeah so maybe starting with this with
the second one um private philanthropy
does now and has for a long time
supported lots of research including
basic research um that's absolutely true
um I think to answer the question again
I would look to historical examples um
and so if you look at the the reasons
why and the the events that led to the
creation of the National Institutes of
Health it's quite interesting because uh
what what happened was as I mentioned in
my opening remarks a group of reformers
inspired by wartime research this
actually speaking of uh you know the
dirty underbelly of of science funding
they were particularly inspired by two
things which was research on venial
disease and the bilding of chemical
weapons um but the the model of
coordinated research which was the
Federal Government providing an
infrastructure and ultimately funding
for academic research to solve a
practical problem inspired reformers
after World War I to use it to build a
chemo Medical Research Institute as they
called it and they wanted it to be
private the scientific Community wanted
it to be private the uh industry
initially uh was very interested and
wanted to be private and in even many of
the Statesmen that they spoke to wanted
it to to remain a private institution
they were unsuccessful in getting
sufficient private support to launch The
Institute um in including from private
philanthropists and from industry uh and
and really only quite reluctantly uh
turned to the federal government because
of ranell that particular Senator uh who
was very uh uh bullish about public uh
involvement here and that led to the
creation of NIH think there are other
examples like that from history which I
think illustrate not that the private
sector private philanthropy won't fund
research but sometimes there is a
misalignment between what the goals
might be and it and the federal
government in those instances can play a
very valuable role um comment from you
uh Terrence on that question and answer
well um I'm going to quote mtha who's
the director of the Burrows welcome fund
who back in 1993 I think she's still
running it by the way she said we've
seen foundations move away from medical
research because the government has
moved in so even foundations recognize
that when the state has moved in they'll
find other things to F this is a classic
example of crowding out actually Tony
and I have really drill down today we
agree on practically everything apart
from the point that you've identified it
does come out to crowding out crowding
out is real it happens and that is why
it's such a damaging thing and and that
is where Tony and I disagree because
Tony I don't know what your position on
crowding out is but I've never seen you
talk about it or write about it ever and
I would argue in the nicest possible way
though I didn't like it the way you
looked at me when you significantly when
you were talking about veneral disease
research I don't know what my wife has
told you
um I think that that is the hole I would
pick and I'm being very courteous I hope
but that is the hole I'd pick in your
argument I think you need to address
crowding out that's what I would say I
hope you're not offended okay you want
to say something yeah because that was
the second part that I didn't get to so
I think crowding out certainly real I I
don't deny that that that can happen I
think part of the difficulty um I guess
there are two two challenges well maybe
maybe add three I do read the economics
literature uh differently than you um
you can find uh economists that make
more persuasive versions of aru
Arguments for federal support than the
Nelson and era arguments that are very
easy I think to criticize um that said I
I don't think it's fundamentally an
economic argument I think it's an
argument of of how we understand the
state's role and the nature of
scientific Enterprise so I I don't draw
from economics literature ultimately to
make my to make my arguments um I think
part of the challenge is how we Define
research right so there are different
areas of research um and the
relationship between basic and and and
applied is is quite slippery um and I
think that's one of the challenges here
is that when the federal government is
involved in an area of research it can
wind up funding lots of basic research
NSF is the only agency in the federal
government whose sole purpose more or
less is to fund basic research um you we
probably disagree about how good that
model is for different reasons but it's
important to keep in mind that it's one
agency its budget is Tiny compared to
the overall uh Federal research
establishment and many other agencies
due today and have historically moved
into basic research not entirely um but
because of the recognition of it of its
practical importance and so I think it's
more a question of what the area of
research is and the Innovations in
question and how the incentives align a
different context I think it's very
difficult to generate a kind of formula
to that we can apply to every instance
and I think the other challenge is that
aggregate statistics can be very Mis
very misleading in lots of ways um you
know the examples I gave uh generated
all kinds of benefits that are difficult
to capture in all sorts of economic
terms and I completely agree with you
that there are a number of studies
including one by the office of
Technology assessment from the early
1990s which um shows that traditional
economic measures are not adequate to uh
to capture um the effects of federal
spending that report does not conclude
therefore that the federal government
shouldn't play a role um it also points
out in that same report it's worth
adding that Private Industry doesn't use
those very measures itself uh because
they are inadequate um and if we look at
aggregate statistics we also find um you
know sort of
aggregate facts which can be interpreted
in lots of different ways one I'm
curious to hear what you think about is
that in the postwar period when the
federal government was at its peak of
federal funding including not quite at
its peak of federal funding basic but
basic science if you look over time as a
share of federal R&D is more or less
constant it's gone up in recent decades
overall but it's not it's never been
very large actually applied science has
never been that large either Lon share
goes to development research especially
by the military but this is true even
outside that and but if you look at then
Private Industry Private Industry now
spends uh relatively large amounts um on
basic science um compared to the
historical record although it's about 7%
it's self-reported data there may be
issues about how to classify it but if
you look at the postar decades it spent
about the same percentage on basic
science at a moment when the federal
government was by far the largest fun of
of of research now one might infer from
that that there's no crowding out going
out going on there my my uh instinct is
to say that we need to drill down deeper
than those aggregate data and to get a
better sense of what's really going on
if you can take one minute to respond uh
but just a minute uh or do you want to
pass Daren very one minute very very
quickly since Tony's agreed me I want to
agree with Tony on one thing which is
there is a role for the government
funding of science I do accept that but
it's it's defensive it's protecting us
from industry and other potential Bad
actors I mean uh we want a democratic
government to be fully equipped to
understand the dangers of AI for example
um it's an appalling example and I I
very much regret having to say it but it
is absolutely true that the person who
led the research that showed us that
cigarettes cause lung cancer of all
loathsome people was Adolf Hitler so
governments do have a role in
challenging industry um so I want to
agree with you to that limit but let's
not pretend it's going to give economic
growth cuz it just doesn't first
question i' ask you like a question
don't have to identify yourself take it
away go ahead so uh I have one question
but in two parts what I'm sorry one
question in two parts is this okay one
question in two parts okay first part
goes to uh Mr Mills uh so you gave us
lots of uh examples of successful
science successful research uh and uh it
kind of gave us false impression that uh
uh government funded signs always so
successful uh if you listen for example
to Senator Ren Paul uh he sometimes uh
gives speech about unsuccessful
government funded research which is
ridiculous not only it's unsuccessful
but it's wasteful so uh what makes you
think that uh if we would leave all this
money which government takes from the
private sector and makes all this
research uh and the private sector will
do Instead This research it will not be
more successful better research better
science earlier discoveries and so on
this is one and to well that's your
question fine your question is and
second part to forgive me you asked a
question and that was good very good
question your question was doesn't
government uh often engage in
unsuccessful research did I summarize
that correctly yes yes yes okay uh and I
guess the challenges for Tony T sure
yeah well I'll make it even harder for
myself maybe by quibbling with the first
part of your question so the historical
examples I gave are not examples of the
Federal Government funding science and
then generating technological innovation
you we'd have to look Case by case
whether baray was receiving he did
receive funding from you know the French
State um there are a lot of different
actors in different countries the French
government that funded bar doesn't exist
anymore because you know it was uh a lot
of things happened in France in the 19th
century um you know so uh that's not the
purpose of the ill the historical
examples I gave um the purpose of those
examples was to illustrate the complex
ways in which basic scientific
discoveries can enable technological
innovation often over very long periods
of time um and this gets to the second
part of your question um it's certainly
true that the federal government could
could fund um wasteful things in science
as in other domains I think the
challenge is what do we Define as
wasteful so if we had uh let's say the
federal government had decided to give a
grant to George bull in the 1840s uh to
do research on mathematical logic well
we couldn't have done that actually
because mathematical logic didn't really
exist yet as a discipline but to do
whatever it was that he was doing um and
then 5 years later 10 years later 20
years later 50 years later had said was
there a good return on on investment the
answer would probably have been no um
there was certainly awareness of the
utility of what his work and related
work um could could imply efforts to
build calculating machines were already
underway by uh Stanley jevans um in the
1870s or 80s of memory serves um partly
inspired by bu's work livits had
tinkered with building a a calculating
machine uh because he had intuited some
of the the discoveries that bu had made
much much later so the idea of something
practical was around but no one had done
anything really to show for it uh until
the 1930s and even then if we had given
a grant to Claude Shannon and said you
know see if you can make use of George
Bull's research and come back in five
years there would have been no computer
yet really at least nothing like uh the
computers that were developed by uh the
federal government in in in the US and
by the British government during World
War II so it's very difficult to apply
uh you know simple Roi metric on uh
scientific uh research particularly
basic science and that's one of the
reasons why I think uh the SC that the
state does have a role to play in the
long term uh comment Terence very
briefly um one of the things is that
government agencies resist audit um
Michael Pur who is a professor of
Economics at MIT has tried repeatedly to
audit how effective DARPA or arpa is
they just won't give him the data uh and
arpa had lots of failures to its name
like for example project agile in in
Vietnam and yes I agree with Tony about
uh some of the examples he's given but
the British government was unbelievably
generous to babage in the middle of the
19th century with his difference engines
a fortune they gave him an absolute
fortune and produced absolutely nothing
next question it's question for both
speakers um in my experience as an
academic research scientist little more
little louder into the mic yes um basic
Government funding of basic science
research is much more likely to make
that basic science research prone to
politicization and also to Scientific
fraud fraudulent data fraudulent
methodologies as compared to
uh basic science research funded by the
private sector I think a clear example
of this is climate science research over
the past 40 50 years I'm curious if
either of you have any data to speak to
that in more general terms um well let's
have Terence go first for the moment yes
well uh you're quite right of course and
I would refer you to an essay that you
know very well um in new Atlantis um uh
by that Arizona State University
academic Dan sarz Daniel saravitz a very
accessible essay it's on the web and he
Absol he's called how to save science or
something he absolutely recognizes
saving science I believe it's called
thank you he absolutely recognizes the
point that you've made that science has
been horribly politicized and actually
hugely damage the example I would give
is food research um and I once wrote a
book uh called um breakfast is a
dangerous meal uh in
which it's it's not really nutrition
advice it is the longest lasting example
I know of of non-reproducible science
for over a 100 years nutrition
scientists many of them on government
grants have written rubbish about
breakfast for all sorts of reasons and
but you know fat and all the rest of it
so you're absolutely right and actually
my guess is that Tony will agree with me
um Tony go ahead yeah we yeah we agree
on that so we haven't really one thing
that we didn't get into maybe we can get
into more we're getting into it now is
the problems with the current system so
my argument is not that the way the
federal government currently funds
science is perfect and should continue
as such I I would even go farther and
say it's frequently the case in public
policy debates and here Terence and I
agree um that in the science policy
realm at least the the reflex is well
these agencies just need more money um
and it's an important fact about the
creation of the federal scientific
establishment that it transforms
scientists into claimant among others
for public resources um that's just a
sociological description um and so we
should take the arguments that they make
with with a grain of salt um uh that
doesn't mean that all of what I said in
my opening remarks is therefore you know
not true the question about how to make
this the federal scientific
establishment function better which is a
very important public policy question is
one that we can and should have um what
I would argue particularly to your
question about you know incentives and
um encouraging of um perverse research
incentives that can that can generate
fraud or maybe in you know fraud is
certainly a problem but more frequent
than that are research practices that
are frankly just shoddy that generate
unreliable research um I guess I would
just say two two more quick things about
this first uh the the areas of science
that are most plagued by replication
problems are not basic Sciences really
um they are um well we could debate
about how to describe what kind of
research psychology is but psychology is
where the the replication issue um
originated at least in the early 2000s
um there there are Sciences in which
there's a very important and very
peculiar role for statistical methods
and debates about how to apply and
misapply those go back all the way to
the 1950s um biomedical research is is
certainly impacted um but you know
quantum physics isn't having a
replication crisis um so I think that's
an important datm that we would want to
use if we're going to try to you know
generate a fuller explanation about
what's going on on here the second thing
I would say is that there is a good
argument to be made and I I would make
it If This Were a different debate that
the way the federal government is
funding so-called basic science in many
instances doesn't really amount to basic
science and for precisely the reasons
that you've intuited uh there's a
passage um in Michael Palani a figure
that I'll probably come back to later U
who was an who who shared my viewpoint
um he says somewhere that uh if Western
governments adopt the Soviet model of
asking for a certificate of social util
utility before funding scientists it
would be a disaster for the scientific
Enterprise that's exactly what science
agencies do now including basic
scientific agencies like the NSF almost
literally have a certificate of of
social utility um and so you know
there's a whole debate about this going
on in science policy circles and people
have different viewpoints of politics um
have come I think to an emerging
agreement that this is not not the best
way to to to to to go about things but
this isn't a problem with basic science
per se this is a problem with the
institutions that we we currently have
okay uh next
question yeah Terren um I think the
crowding out argument is very compelling
but isn't that much more of an argument
about the way basic science is funding
funded rather than whether it is funded
isn't a policy such as say the research
and development tax credit basically
science funded but through the private
sector and not crowding out but the
total
opposite well the trouble with tax
credits is twofold first um there's an
awful lot of fiddling the moment you
have tax credits company accountants
suddenly discover that everything is R&D
and therefore can be tax credited uh and
that is a real problem but the other
problem is you assume that there's a
problem with R&D that somehow we need
more R&D actually it's not at all clear
that is the case um there diminishing
returns in capital there are diminishing
returns in labor and actually there are
diminishing returns in R&D and you can
actually have too much R&D I've never
seen a convincing argument that we
actually need tax credits for R&D um I
mean I look at the pharmaceutical
industry they spend more money on
marketing than on R&D they're not short
of money if they wanted to spend more
money on R&D they easily could if you
look at the budgets of companies like
Amazon what's 45 billion these companies
don't need tax credits I've never seen
an incy argument that we actually need
tax credits for R&D uh comment uh the
only thing I would add is that um we
probably in agreement on this that um um
even in the the public sector there's
there's no op prior argument for why
budget should always increase right
there could be diminishing returns in in
that domain as well um so you know the
argument for whether the federal
government should fund basic science at
all should be distinguished from how
much money the federal government should
spend on basic science or any other kind
of research next
question hi you spoke about the
discoveries of close the mic sorry you
spoke about discoveries of nitro
nitrogen you come to the the other
situation of a person like lavier who
discovered oxygen where the government
itself based on
ideology executed him and then you have
in the Soviet Union people like toim
lenko the issue is not necessarily the
loss of money or the crowd in out but
governments driven by
ideology uh do how the impact of what
are the impacts of governments driven by
ideology pushing science backwards based
on whatever the prevailing ideology is
of the day oh I guess yeah it's a great
question it's it's a problem so the
example you gave the Soviet Union is a
good one um the bukharan who was in
charge of Soviet uh science policy uh
for a certain period before he was uh
shouldn't laugh before he was killed um
by the Soviet government um he was in
charge of a program of of central
planning essentially a 5-year program
that would direct science to socially
useful lenss um the Soviets didn't
believe in the idea of basic science
because they thought that science had to
be in Conformity with with party
ideology um it was actually uh in
opposition to that very model that
people like Michael Palani developed uh
the account that I'm giving of federal
support for basic science without
control um in the way that the Soviets
did for example so there is real problem
there the question is what kind of state
are we are we talking about if we're in
a liberal State we're going to have a
very different model for the
relationship between science and state
than when we would have in a
totalitarian uh State or the aan
regime yes go ahead yes but the the
trouble is the moment the state gets
involved even in America so um in 1917
when America joined the Western Front
American army airplanes were all
borrowed from the British the belgians
and the French you did not have an
American aviation industry and the
reason for that was the rright brothers
had flown as a private Enterprise in
1903 and therea the federal government
in association of course with um
um the Smith sonian institution who had
received the original Grant until 1917
consistently denied and lied there's no
other word for it just lied that the Bri
Brothers had not developed the airplane
because they wanted the glory of the
airplane for themselves they can get
more Government research grants
basically the moment the government gets
involved in anything it's going to
corrupt even a democratic government
like yours next
question hello guys uh gentlemen what do
you think about the idea that because
the government doesn't operate on the
profit and loss system that whatever it
spends resources on is necessarily
resource destructive and how do you
think that idea applies to this debate
uh Terrence take that well hyek would
certainly agree with
you um look I I I'm going to agree with
you but I'll let Tony expand on why we
both agree with
you um Tony I think you disagree yeah
yeah I mean I think it depends on what
what our goals are right so I think we
can point to examples where uh the
federal I mean if we look at the history
of Federal science there are lots of
examples of successes the difficulty is
that it can't run a controlled
experiment to know you know what would
have happened um otherwise um so I I
think it is hard to as I said earlier I
think it's very difficult to generalate
a universal formula that can we that we
can apply that's going to give us the
correct policy output in any given
context I think what we can do is look
at the instances where the federal
government has done things well and
where it's done it badly the private
sector has done it well where it's done
it badly um and that is a very
complicated picture there are examples
where you know uh which again we haven't
talked a lot about and I'd be curious to
hear Terence what you think about um uh
Federal funding of health research there
are lots of examples of of benefits that
have come from federal funding of of
medical and biomedical research that
might be very difficult to capture in
economic terms that ultimately have lots
of benefits um an example uh is the work
of on cancer research in the 1970s which
played an important role and the AIDS
epidemic response of the 1980s no one
could have anticipated that work done in
the 7s on that would have been helpful
for something a prac a practical problem
that was quite different um and there
are lots of other examples that we could
look to and there are examples where the
relationship between the state and
Industry and science is quite different
operation warp speed during covid-19 was
one model um and World War II provides a
plethora of examples of different models
so I don't have a unified field Theory
um that can sort of generate policy
outputs I tend to shy away from that way
of thinking about policy uh this will
have to be the final question sorry
about come to the party talk to the guys
afterwards go ahead yes um I would like
to look into
physics we have the big colliders and
the big um
no not microscopes what are they the
word what's the word telescopes h telesc
ah looking for the word particle
accelerators the big machines to look
into to the
sky thank you yeah uh the no industry
would fund that and we had a similar
example in quantum physics where only
after many many decades suddenly the
industry is getting interesting
interested so how can we bridge that
Gap um I think that's a challenge for
Terrence what about the telescopes
Terence just for
starters name a telescope until recently
that wasn't funded by the private sector
the 19th century is full of these great
telescopes created by the private sector
and the 20th century is full of radio
telescopes invented by pel labs in the
private sector the most romantic branch
of science is astronomy and astronomy
has never been short of the private
funding ass science who invented space
uh travel who invented the space Rockets
Mooney Godard he invented the rocket he
invented the stages he invented the
liquid fuels he invented the guiding
mechanisms all on Guggenheim money uh
astronomy is the one science that
doesn't need a penny of Public Funding
because the world is full of
multi-millionaires look at seti the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
the moment Congress said there are no
little green men out there Silicon
Valley just took over and setting now
has more money than it knows what to do
with don't worry about astronomy it's
always been fine okay um I'm going to
have to that we run out of time for the
Q&A Tony you're going to do your five
minutes rebuttal and you may want to
trash what ter just said in your
rebuttal so uh do you want to do it from
the there I'll Stand Up do it from here
okay you can take
extra so I've tried to convince you that
the public has a vested interest in
sustaining the conditions for a vibrant
ecosystem of Discovery and invention and
that a key part of that is the
flourishing culture of basic science my
argument is that the state can has and
should continue to play a vital role in
ensuring that basic science receives
adequate support but rather than trying
to persuade you of that one more time in
my my summary remarks here I want to
Pivot a little bit step back and think
about the political context of my
argument and I want to consider
something that I think is particularly
topical given our venue which is whether
the argument that I'm making is a
statist anti-free market argument
which Terrence is too polite to accuse
me of but I think is implied in many of
his uh comments so my position is that
the state should fund basic science I'm
not saying anything here tonight about
whether the state should control science
is that a statist argument it's worth
noting that one of the most important
arguments on behalf of the point of view
I'm advocating tonight was in fact
articulated by a Conservative Republican
one who was mentioned earlier vanever
Bush who was in fact arguing against
Central planning by the state Bush was
the chief of research during World War
II and the success of the research
programs he oversaw persuaded many that
the state should continue to steer
science toward National go goals after
the war the American Science writer vmar
camport captured this idea well in a
1943 article titled the case for Planned
research La Fair he wrote has has been
abandoned as an economic principle it
should also be abandoned at least as a
matter of government policy in science
end quote it was an opposition to this
idea backed by New Deal liberals such as
Senator Harley Kilgore of West Virginia
and political allies of President
Roosevelt and later Truman that bush
made his famous case for federal funding
of basic science during peace time in an
influential report titled science the
endless Frontier Bush pointed out that
the fundamental scientific discoveries
that had made wartime Technologies
possible that made Mission research
successful predated the war and were
generally not the result of any
pre-planned effort governmental or
otherwise they are the kinds of basic
scientific discoveries that I that I
described in my opening
remarks though he was President
Roosevelt's science adviser Bush was in
fact an anti-new deal conservative and
he feared that perpetuating the
government's wartime and Military
controls and bureaucratic controls
excuse me into peace time would erode
scientific freedom and indeed Democratic
freedom in trying to sell basic science
uh in its contribution to the public
interest Bush admittedly oversold this
case overemphasized its link to
Innovation incautiously suggesting that
technologies will freely flow from
pursuit of science for its own sake here
Dan s Switz whom Terren mentioned and I
agree but here Bush could have learned
from his contemporary and fellow critic
of central planning the Hungarian
polymath Michael Palani whom I mentioned
earlier Pani had been embroiled in a
very similar debate dating back all the
way to the 1930s when an influential
group of British Bri scientists inspired
by the Soviet method of central planning
argu that the state should not only fund
science but steer it toward political
goals a fierce critic of Soviet
communism Palani rejected this idea on
principle arguing that science is a
spontaneous order that cannot be planned
in advance an idea echoed by his friend
frieder kayek for Palani as for Bush the
problem was not State funding of science
but State planning of science though
both recognized that safeguards would be
needed to keep such funding from
becoming Central planning
P's case for basic science or as he
preferred to call it pure science was
ultimately a political or even a moral
one not an economic one Advocates of
planning he argued saw science as little
more than an instrument for political
power while conceding that science can
and does contribute many practical
benefits to society Pani insisted that
science be defended on non-utilitarian
grounds though originally articulated in
opposition to Soviet style planning and
its Western apologists this moral case
for Pure science is is no less relevant
today with a growing of liberalism on
both left and right which treats
scientific ideals as little more than
instruments of power resisting such
instrumentalism Pia advocated a liberal
culture in which science could flourish
for its own sake thereby contributing
not only to Scientific and technological
progress but also to the preconditions
of a free Society the state has an
important if limited role to play here
not in planning science but as Palani
himself put it in providing the
opportunities for its pursuit to do less
he wrote is to neglect the progress of
science thank
[Applause]
you look I'm a great fan of Michael
Palani um um and actually if any of absh
was a great man as well but what they
wanted was absurd they wanted lift it up
a little bit I'm a great fan of Michael
Palani and of course of vanar bush but
what they wanted was absurd they wanted
government money money without
accountability to the government very
famously in 1947 President Truman vetoed
the First National Science Foundation
bill because that was exactly what it
provided government money to scientists
without accountability to government you
can't have it that's a fantasy it's
never going to happen um and you don't
need it the private sector generates
tons of pure science itself so almost
all not all but almost all the pure
science that Tony quite rightly says was
the basis of the mission science of the
second world war period was actually
generated by the market or by
philanthropy or by like unusual
individuals in the previous 100 years
not exclusively of course the French and
German governments produced something
useful but essentially the basic science
that was being used by British and
American scientists after the second
world war had come from the era of l a
fair in science so I think the and I'm
just repeating myself now I think the
key is crowding out and I think there is
I'm not going to say a conspiracy of
Silence because we're sophisticated
people here and we know that conspiracy
theories are wrong but there's such a
total alignment of every vested interest
industry scientists
universities politicians that no one has
really addressed properly the Ser the
question of crowding out uh which I
think damages in fact crowding out is
why we can't have the government funding
of science uh and I will only concede
that governments should fund science to
challenge industry it was important for
example to challenge the tobacco
companies there are times when a
democratic poity must have technological
capacity of its own so it can challenge
say Ai and actually Tony wrote a really
good article a few years ago about the
office of Technology assessment which
empowered the Democratic legislature
here in the states against not just the
executive but also against industry and
there we are agreed but when it comes to
economics and economic growth and
perhaps the odd orphan industry but
forgetting uh com uh disease but when it
comes to economic growth we must stop
thinking that the government funding of
pure science or indeed even applied
science will do anything other than at
best nothing bad but probably will hold
it back because of crowding out thank
you I have in my hand the tonu the so
form Tootsie Roll so please take out
your uh machines and vote yes no or
undecided on the resolution government
must play a role in fostering scientific
and technological progress by funding
basic research yes no or decided on that
resolution while you're voting of course
again uh both uh Debaters have kindly
consented to come to our Afterparty
those of you in particular who didn't
get your questions answered uh you can
see they're both extremely approachable
friendly guys and uh so you can ask them
your questions then that's two blocks
Uptown most of many of you know where it
is just follow the crowd 55 great Jones
Street uh a uh an announcement about
what's to come on our next debate will
be February 26th that's a Monday and uh
the debate will uh resolution will read
the root cause of the Israeli
Palestinian conflict is the Palestinians
rejection of Israel's right to exist
that will be between two journalists Eli
Lake and Jeremy Hammond it will will be
held at a different Venue at the Soho
Playhouse way to the West in SoHo on
vanam street it's a 168 seat theater
that mostly does plays it does have it
downstairs for reception afterwards I
will tell you that perhaps naively I was
surprised to learn this morning that
sales for that uh event are really
taking off already
and so I do urge you uh uh when you get
home tonight uh buy your ticket because
we may well be sold out there are those
who suggested to me that I try a larger
venue than the Soho playhouse but I sort
of like the idea that it's tucked away
in SoHo a little bit away from the
crowds so that possibly disruptive
demonstrators will not know that we're
holding the debate and so that's one of
the advantages of having in the in that
pocket it it's a very nice stadium
seating theater of 168 seats but uh the
sales are uh really soaring so if you
want to go I suggest you uh you buy your
ticket as soon as possible we'll
probably have to declare soldout status
for that event fairly quickly uh uh
Grant I'm seeing you not and you uh and
okay the uh I have the tis in my hand
it's going to be tossed to the
winner yes okay um yes okay um all right
uh government must play a role in foring
scientific and Technologic research by
funding Bic basic re the yes vote went
from
28.9 to 27.8 so it lost one point uh the
no vote went from 33 to 68 it gained 35
points so the uh the
CH thank you to both Debaters for a very
civil debate from which I learned a
great deal thank you both Tony and
[Applause]
Terrence